WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
UNITED STATES AND TALK ABOUT
ENDING HIS NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT READY
TO CALL IT A BREAK THROUGH BUT
HE IS OPTIMISTIC THAT THE OFFER
ON NORTH KOREA TO END ITS NEWARK
PROGRAM MAY BEAR FRUIT.
HE MADE A JOKE WHEN ASKED WHAT
BROUGHT NORTH TO THIS POINT?
>> ME.
[LAUGHING].
NOBODY GOT THAT.
>> THE PRESIDENT TOOK CREDIT FOR
THE HARSH SANCTIONS THAT HE SAID
HELPED BRING NORTH KOREA AROUND.
HE SAID THE U.S. HELPED MAKE THE
RECENT SOUTH KOREA OLYMPIC A
SUCCESS AND HAD PRAISE FOR NORTH
KOREA PARTICIPATION.
>> I THOUGHT NORTH KOREA WAS
TERRIFIC.
THEY CAME OUT AND WENT INTO THE
OLYMPICS WITH GOOD SPIRIT AND
DID WELL.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN CARRY THAT
OVER.
IT MAY OR MAY NOT.
IT'S A VERY TENUOUS SITUATION.
IT WILL BE INTEREST TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID WE WILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH NORTH
KOREA.
FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR BOLDEN
BELIEVES THE PROMISE OF TALK IS
A RUSE BY THE NORTH TO BUY TIME.
>> THE ONLY THING NORTH KOREA IS
ABOUT IS GETTING DELIVERABLE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AND THEY ARE
CLOSE TO ACHIEVING AN OBJECTIVE
THEY HAVE BEEN AFTER FOR 25
YEARS.
WHY DO THEY WANT TO TALK NOW?
TO DIVERT OR ATTENTION AND GET
ACROSS THAT FINISH LINE.
>> THE THREAT OF PUNITIVE
TARRIFS ON STEEL AND ALUMINUM
WAS HIGH ON THE AGENDA.
LEVINE CARRYING A MESSAGE FROM
THE EUROPEAN UNION THAT ANY
AMERICAN TARIFF WILL BE MET WITH
PENALTIES AGAINST U.S. GOODS
MADE IN REPUBLICAN DISTRICTS
LIKE MOTORCYCLE, JEANS AND
BOURBON.
>> THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS BEEN
TOUGH ON THE U.S.
IT MAKES IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
DO BUSINESS WITH THEM BUT THEY
SEND THEIR CARS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE BACK INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY CAN DO WHATEVER THEY WOULD
LIKE.
IF THEY DO THAT, THEN WE PUT A
BIG TAX OF 25% ON THEIR CARS AND
THEY WON'T DO IT LONG.
>> HOW DO YOU AVOID A TRADE WAR?
>> WE WILL HAVE TO SEE.
WHEN WE ARE BEHIND ON EVERY
SINGLE COUNTRY, TRADE WARS ARE
NOT SO BAD?
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT I MEAN?
WE ARE DOWN BY 100 BILLION
DOLLARS, THE TRADE WAR HURTS
THEM.
IT DOESN'T HURT US.
WE WILL STRAIGHTEN IT OUT AND DO
IT IN A VERY LOVING WAY.
A LOVING, LOVING WAY.
THEY WILL LIKE US BETTER AND
THEY WILL RESPECT US MUCH MORE.
>> WHEN ASKED HOW FORCEFUL THE
MESSAGE HE CARRIED TO THE
PRESIDENT WAS THE PRIME MINISTER
DEFLECTED.